[Musique]
des livres pour interroger et imaginer
le monde c'est la devise des éditions
rue du monde installé à voisins le
bretonneux la maison fête cette année
ses 20 ans pour cet anniversaire une
librairie versaillaise a souhaité rendre
hommage à ces illustrateurs en discutant
avec l'éditeur on a décidé ensemble
proposer ces six illustrateurs qui sont
tout à fait représentatif de l'esprit
des images ce qui moi me touche c'est
que ce côté très engagé de leur travail
que ce soit dans la couleur la forme ou
une petite folie par exemple je trouve
que de passé énormément de temps à
dessiner les oiseaux en costume ça il
une certaine poésie là dedans qui me
plaît beaucoup
des personnages déguisés de vanessa hié
aux couleurs vives de laurent corvaisier
le visiteur embarque dans un univers à
mi-chemin entre fantastique et réalité
réalisés à l'encré de chine les oeuvres
2 à lui sont une invitation au voyage
j'aime bien d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup
voyagé à dissimuler les gens
j'espère que ça donne envie aux gens
d'aller voir ailleurs je m'aperçois du
bouclage est fléché un monde ça parle de
cavage de racisme de cuisine du monde
quelque chose comme ça qu'ils sont nous
fait des thèmes 2-2 en éruption qui me
convienne parfaitement dans le cadre de
la visite des lectures et ateliers
créatifs sont mises en place autour des
artistes jusqu'à la fin des vacances
scolaires avec un spectacle le samedi 11
février en compagnie du chapiteau méli
mélo